it was a hastily arranged news
conference at the pentagon
following a meeting of the national
security council the secretary of
defense announced the further deployment
of u.s forces to the middle east
the intention he said to bolster the
defense systems of saudi arabia and the
united arab emirates
the president has approved the
deployment of u.s forces
which will be defensive in nature and
primarily focused on air and missile
defense
we will also work to accelerate the
delivery of military equipment to the
kingdom of saudi arabia
and the uae to enhance their ability to
defend themselves
it's not clear how many troops the u.s
will provide
but the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff emphasized this was a defensive
deployment and indicated the u.s would
ask its allies
to offer their support we're
contributing to saudi arabia's defense
we would be looking as the secretary
said for other international partners to
also
contribute to saudi arabia's defense the
secretary of defense continued to insist
iran was responsible for the attacks on
saudi oil installations last weekend
brushing off repeated iranian denials of
involvement
but at the same time confirming that the
u.s forensic team working with saudi
experts
had still not concluded its
investigation
news of the deployment closely followed
president trump's decision to impose new
sanctions on iran
at the end of the day as president trump
hosts a dinner for the prime minister of
australia
it appears that the u.s economic
pressure will be buttressed by a show
of military force even if at this stage
it is declared to be
of a defensive nature mike hannah
al-jazeera washington